good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast live and in living
color thank you that's what they say on
hairspray welcome back to the morning
toast we are back in studio but in a new
studio for those of you who have noticed
hello welcome to our new studio we had
some issues don't ask we were here now
we moved we're so excited to be back
this is so weird that goodness is so
weird
so weird like this I feel weird being
there you know like this whole thing is
so weird it has been a few months since
we started zooming from home got it I
mean I just it's a totally different
season I'm like in a sweater and jeans
even though it's 80 degrees outside I
just I never had time to shop for the
summer and now it's like the summers
upon us and we're not cool for the
summer not at all I'm actually very warm
for the summer ya know it's rough but
we'll get back into it you know even the
few times we were able to do podcast
episodes together in quarantine like
they're just so much funnier they're
better and I think it was eighties time
for us to be back together
it's very excited eating you with that
good morning Millennials fortunately it
means that hyd such hyoeun is gonna take
a back seat day they'll always have her
you know and we'll always like have had
that together that's that controversy
it's devastating it is devastating I'm
heartbroken
you look heartbroken we have an amazing
show for you guys as you know it's
Wednesday it's hump day which means I'm
someone you love I'll be humping Jackie
later even though she social distance
okay fine I'll hump Theo and that also
means we have deer toasters which is art
by segments so if he or someone you know
was looking for advice feel free to
write in we always keep it anonymous and
we'll be doing that at the end of the
show today but before that yeah we're
busy we have so much to discuss we
actually have some really good stories
to talk about and just life you know
what I'm still so sore like I truly can
not that I need to move on the show like
I can't get up what are you sore from
from working out I did a live math
education and like it broke me yeah me
too i was like begging the trainer am i
please let's do more let's do more
holding that plank like you were going
over time yeah and he was just like
Claudia you're you're gonna overdo it
and like okay Matt I'll stop
yeah well I feel like so much has
changed since we last did a show like in
a studio I'm a whole new person I feel
like I might even look different on
camera
I feel like this quarantine has aged me
basically mentally emotionally like we
are all just different people than we
were and I'm looking forward to seeing
how I look on camera cuz I feel like I
have a different thought well yeah I'm
looking forward to seeing the 12 pounds
that I gained we'll see they say the
camera adds 10 pounds right and I need
12 18 22 pounds 22 pounds so let me know
if I look any different
also disclaimer as with any new studio
you know things take time we have some
fabulous wallpaper coming a new neon
sign so just bear with us while we work
through you know the crooks and crannies
of being studio owners ya know I'm
excited about this space it's it's
fabulous and it's gonna become more and
more fabulous yeah we've got lots of big
big plans yeah big big plans speaking of
I've really been thinking about like
Lauren Lane Ben Higgins ever since I
watched like that season they just took
me back did you see her Instagram story
yesterday where she was like wow I got
so many messages about me like not like
posting or like acknowledging that my
season was on then she's like and while
I'm so grateful for the opportunity and
like I've no ill feelings about
production or Ben or anything like I
have moved on with my life and I just
not gonna watch it and I'm not gonna
post about it which I thought I can't
believe anyone was expecting married
like yeah I can't believe anyone was
expecting her to even like acknowledge
it yeah I wasn't expecting that makes a
ton of sense I really wasn't expecting I
didn't even notice that she didn't you
know sing because I'm just like whoever
that person was on my TV like that's not
Lauren lis
right and like I mean I don't follow her
but to Jo Jo post about it well Jo Jo
was on the episode like Chris called her
and to talk about the heartbreak and
then next week is her season Oh her
season was on my favorite she's really
like stealing The Bachelor fold whereas
like Lauren lean has graduated from
Bachelor University big time she made it
to the big leagues she's like going to
grad school yeah yeah she's getting her
MBA in country music oh my god it's
fabulous well I am so happy for her and
like her perfect little life in
Nashville like I'm so jealous of her
house she just got a new pendant
in her kitchen last night I'm just
obsessed with her I didn't think it was
weird
um in terms of them like now going
through and playing new seasons like I'm
really not crazy about Jojo season like
to me it wasn't ever really like a
season it was just like her and Jordan
like protect trying to pretend that they
didn't know each other before you're in
joining like acting their way through a
season attending like they like other
people or that they might not be here
for each other totally like it's just
it's honestly wasting your time don't
watch it yeah well we'll see I honestly
I enjoyed I enjoyed watching it the
other night maybe was cuz was been
season so I'm gonna give it another
chance cuz it was definitely value-add
okay my evenings okay
so I guess without further ado it's time
I've also been watching Real Housewives
of Potomac just getting through season
four right now they just got back from
New Orleans and like it was just one of
the best trips I've seen again on the
Housewives franchise like it was iconic
ya know I'm I know it was iconic so um
and I would have something to recap and
the TV recap but I was convinced from
tick-tock to watch this well I thought
it was a TV show 365 days have you heard
about it is that the Stockholm Syndrome
like um porn yes yes yes yes yes yes
it was just not at all what I expected I
did not finish it I thought it was a TV
show about like this like you know like
crime family and all of a sudden I'm
watching porn and I wasn't like
necessarily upset about it but it was
just not what I expected you know but
the guy who plays the main character
looks so much like my friend Felipe who
wrote my song toast like I couldn't stop
watching like my friend Felipe in porn
like it was crazy like they look so much
alike but it was not him Wow so you
wouldn't recommend it
it depends do you like porn then I would
if you don't like porn maybe it's just
like not for you how's the story
oh but acting the storyline in the
acting makes it more like porn because
it's like it's so fraudulent and like so
fake and it's just like it's like the
scenes in porn between the Borges right
and honestly that acting really reminded
me of like from Justin to Kelly like
that level of sadness Oh
I mean honestly and then I'm watching it
from Justin to Kelly is an amazing movie
but if you watch it through the lens of
like I'm watching porn every scene is my
they're about to [ __ ] like the acting is
so bad and that's how you know acting is
bad it's like when when you think that
porn is about to start
got it okay good to know I won't be
watching it but no and you definitely
should not watch it I'm watching it then
okay well the boat scene is just I
choose a lot I have a lot on my plate
right now so it's a lot it wouldn't have
to be like number eight on the list no I
just like honestly like I die at the
thought of you watching that movie like
it's just you're so pure like I want to
protect you it's just it's it's a lot
that's all I'll say
okay thanks for the disclaimer yeah I
just watched friends all day like I
really I can't even get myself to watch
a politician season two I just know I
have nothing on my plate yet so much
it's true it's very true okay I think
it's time okay without further ado to
get into the past I story is that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast so nice
to not have to DIY my crimes oh yeah
also after this we have to record a
sound bit for Kelly's mind listening
practice yeah Kelly's mindless news like
the fourth of July okay today's episode
is brought to you by Margaret M Margaret
M understands that in today's hectic
lifestyle women want to look and feel
good with ease but without compromising
style Margaret Emma offers a line of
clothing that is versatile easy to wear
and compliments a woman's figure women
that have already discovered their
slimming pants immediately fell in love
and say that it's the most comfortable
flattering pair they've ever worn the
actual terms they use is addictive they
say the same about the shorts and skirts
Jackie and I went to Montauk this
weekend and we both packed our Margaret
and shorts and we both said the exact
same thing about them we're like they
aren't like the fit I can't even
describe they're so comfortable they're
so flattering and there's like sleek
looking like they're tailored towards
tailored pants tailored skirts but
without a waist your ordinary waist
bands like you can breathe honestly my
life is changed by my Margaret M apparel
no it's a new sensation and Margaret
also makes matching masks yeah some of
the prints of the clothes so like you
can really get your style on I wore the
mask my Instagram story and I got so
many messages so you can get them to
match your apparel which is so cute they
use memory stretch fabric that holds the
body together for maximum comfort and a
slimming effect they have a wide range
prints that go from classic to fund
their garments are all made in Canada
Canada proud toasty Canadians our
garments can be put in your washing
machine to buy expensive dry-cleaning
bills they're all versatile enough to
wear to work or casually and they are
available in sizes extra small through
double XL plus sizes 1x - 3 X depending
on the selected styles so we love
wearing our Margaret and masks shorts
pants so flattering so you know silic
feminine you know what really knows how
to flatter your body and it's just a
fabulous brand that we think all the
toasters should know about and if you
want to get 20% off we have an offer for
you guys
20% off and a free face mask by using
the promo code toast they offer
hassle-free returns if you are not
satisfied so if you want to go to
Margaret m dot CA to get 20% off your
first order and a free mask use the
promo code toast at Margaret MCA again
that's promo code toast for 20% off your
first order and to top it off get a free
face mask don't miss out on this great
offer you are going to love it
love it seinem look great first story
and update from yesterday's story the
noose in bubble Wallace's garage has
been there since last fall and the
driver was not the target of a hate
crime says the FBI the news found by a
member of Bubba Wallace's team in his
garage at the Talladega Speedway in
Lincoln Alabama over the weekend has
been in that style since October of last
year the FBI's investigation into the
incident found the FBI determined on
Tuesday that no hate crime had been
committed against Wallace who was the
first black full-time driver to race in
the Cup Series in nearly 50 years they
said after a thorough review of the
facts and evidence surrounding this
event we have concluded that no federal
crime was committed can I just say like
I am thrilled beyond words that this was
I think a misunderstanding so it seemed
so it seems when I was again I'm always
you know just listening to the people I
was reading like tweets and people even
in our Facebook groups
I was curious like what people thought
about this and some people think that
this is like a conspiracy to cover up a
crime and that they're like not fully
satisfied with this result from the
investigation but to me like when I saw
the picture of the garage and I was like
damn that does look like a news but it's
obviously meant to pull down the garage
door I was like oh like this
weird like we just made like a whole
situation about it but I like it's just
now it's like I'm actually really glad
that it obviously didn't happen but I'm
also really glad that like Nascar was
able to support the first and only black
full-time driver yeah so like it's it's
almost like the best of both worlds here
like now we can ask art about to show
their support for their we had a great
moment and the thing that was terrible
wasn't actually so terrible right and so
it actually just is sad because I'm sure
maybe a white driver has seen that news
and not thought anything of it but like
given the current climate and like what
it's like to be a black man in America
you probably just like saw that news it
was like triggered well from what I've
read he didn't see it his crew team saw
it and reported it so it wasn't him that
reported it it was a team well I'm sure
they are just trying to protect him
right of course ultimately this is great
news that like people are not that
[ __ ] evil yeah that this was
hopefully just a misunderstanding and we
had like a really great moment of
solidarity together and now we're like
Nascar stand so yeah I don't know I
think all's well that ends well right oh
yeah we're gonna take the win we're
gonna take the W and Bubba and actually
start his Instagram yesterday because
you were mentioning all the McDonald's
ads and it was like him on a boat eating
chicken nuggets before he's like big
race day and like that is the life I
need like I need to be in ask our wife
I'm gonna get into driving I feel like I
could be a NASCAR passenger like I could
be shotgun doing the music for the
drivers yeah that's not a position but I
was why couldn't it be like there's two
seats in the car totally and I could be
there just like cheer on my music
totally you know telling you like just
which way to go yeah make a right I'm
first timing you can make a stop totally
you know yeah you'll be in charge of
ordering at the drive-thru yeah honestly
NASCAR is like one of the scariest
sports in my opinion it's quite
dangerous clearly you know yeah so this
is we're tying up the story in a lovely
bow hopefully it this is where it ends
and it's all good all good
okay next story new couple alert
boom Timothy sha'lame Oh was started
with a Zagan Zoll is poolside in Cabo
okay very interesting TMZ has the photos
of these two rendezvous in Mexico and
though they're not the couple that I
ever ever would have put together mostly
cuz I don't really think about Timothy
sha'lame like I know he does it for so
many people for me like I just don't
subscribe no he literally like never
crosses my mind
unless he's like he's a picture of him
is placed in front of me right like I've
never I don't think I've ever seen him
in a production of anything no um I
don't follow him on Instagram he's not
really like my type so I don't really
think about him
but I do think about a succumbs Allah's
cuz I think she's like the most
beautiful woman in the world and she's
so nice like we've hung out with her
twice and she's literally the nicest
girl in the world
right and so for these two to come
together we haven't absolutely no choice
but to [ __ ] I have some questions how
old is he I don't know why I think of
him is 15
miju he's 24 and she what and she's 30
oh very pro I think of him as 15 as well
because 15 year-olds love him oh is that
why yeah I just this is gonna be so
controversial I'm like maybe everyone's
gonna like cancel us again but like I
don't see like the Timothy shall obey
like alert yeah I don't understand it
really um cuz to me he's like just like
a skinny kid I went to high school with
with curly hair like I don't understand
like this whole sex pod thing like even
there are people in Hollywood who people
like a lust sober and like I don't like
live for them but I get it like I
respect the lust
I don't get or respect to the Timothy
Shalem a lust yeah I just think like we
have a very specific type yeah and it's
not Timothy sha'lame know and I just I'm
actually like every time I see him I'm
reminded that like how different I am
for my generation you know yeah also
[ __ ] was I wasn't he dating Lily Rose
Deb yes and that was cute and they just
faded off yeah I don't know he's always
he's like become like some like
Hollywood bachelor he is like the guy
which is crazy to me cuz like I don't
even think he's cute like I know
honestly like if we were in high school
and he asked me on a date like I
probably would have said no yeah I don't
get it and like I get so many other like
sex pots like that's what he is like
girls like like Harry Styles like girls
just want to be him like I just don't
get the Timothy sha'lame and also don't
really get out like his name is he
friends sure American I think he's
probably French cuz who spills their
name with it two E's yeah and a she had
a met apostrophe yeah I just I don't get
the whole thing like he he came out of
nowhere
he was sprung onto the scene like if we
watched the movie homie by your name
probably my Rene maybe we should watch a
movie maybe we'd feel differently okay
because I feel like that's where
everyone fell in love with him okay
that's actually a fair call so anyways
I'm happy for this new couple but at
like a Zagan house is everything of the
sort
everything was so she chooses to do with
her time in herself like I support we
have no choice but to respect her as a
queen and a female and an actress
definitely okay next story Jimmy Kimmel
is apologizing for blackface impression
of NBA star Karl Malone Jimmy Kimmel is
apologizing for a black plays impression
he did in the mid to late 1990s the ABC
late-night host who's currently taking a
summer break from Jimmy Kimmel I've
issued the statement on Tuesday it comes
amid a continued reckoning in the
industry over racist depictions of black
people and other people of color in the
past ranging from gone with the wind
being temporary temporarily removed from
HBO max to hulu pulling down four
episodes of 30 rock that featured
blackface scenes Jimmy Kimmel said quote
I have been reluctant to address this as
I knew doing so would be celebrated as a
victory by those who equate apologies
with weakness and cheer for leaders who
use prejudice to divide us that delay
was a mistake there is nothing more
important to me than your respect and I
apologize to those who were genuinely
hurt or offended by the makeup I wore or
the words I spoke the makeup I wore
that's like it's a little soft you know
yeah I mean there's so much weirdness
going on with Jimmy Kimmel and I thought
that his hey this was so strange and
like weirdly timed but it's obvious that
he knew that this was coming out and did
not want to be on air while having to
address this it's much easier to address
it in a statement or with the publicist
then have to go on air and apologize
directly to your audience like that's
it's a very hard thing to do trust me
I've had to do it well he said in his
seat
just cuz he addressed that part that his
summer vacation has been planned for
more than a year and it includes the
next two summers off as well sure
sure Jimmy - sure know what he's saying
sure Jan sure um I mean like I said I
don't really like love Jimmy Kimmel and
I don't think he's funny or really that
like interesting or talented so I'm glad
he's being held accountable for his
actions I just think it's it's and this
is what we said with Jimmy Fallon
- it's like of course doing blackface is
horrible like there's so much historic
historical reasons like why it's so
offensive but like let's also talk about
and like bring in the other people who
like who Jimmy Kimmel doesn't write his
own sketches you know what I mean like
the SN it's like Bourne Michaels like
there's so many people involved and
that's why I like I I love Tina Fey and
like I loved it like she stood up and
was like it's her show and even though I
don't even think she was the one in
blackface like she was the one who
actively like took the episodes down
it's like there's so many more people
involved in a TV show than like just the
person wearing the black face and of
course Jimmy Jimmy Kimmel should have
known better but like at the same time
he was doing his job so like who put him
in that who wrote that skit like this
it's a group thing yeah it takes a lot
of people to approve something one
character right
where did he do the skit was it honest
oh no he did it oh it was a sketch from
Comedy Central right so it's like it
sound like someone's YouTube channel
where like they could potentially like
paint themselves in blackface and then
click live record and then upload it's
not there's so many people involved and
it's like of course Jimmy Kimmel is is
should have 100% be held accountable but
like I also think it's important to know
like how many other people were involved
and how many other people thought this
was like funny and okay
yeah yeah that's that on that that's
that on that Wow but this is just it's
it's a very interesting time to be
working in in Hollywood like it's it is
a sort of reckoning yeah and to have
been working for so long yes so it is
and so we'll keep you posted on what he
does next yeah but it includes a summer
vacation I wonder where he's going
hopefully somewhere I mean where can you
go I don't know I just saw Bella Hadid
and
Elly Baldwin are in Sardinia on a yacht
so we love to be in Sardinia apparently
you can go pursue any of its Europe yeah
fabulous Mediterranean so jealous yeah
okay next story is kind of a throwback
to like the beginning of quarantine when
we were young and fresh and alive
because love is blind start oh my god
okay
Elsie who was like the runner up Ferb
are never split from mark after Reddit
user claimed he was dating another woman
it was love is blind star Elsie has
called it quits with Mark after
rekindling their romance she revealed on
reddit over the weekend that she had
been dating him since early May but
ended things after a user on the website
claimed that he was seeing someone else
in a post titled my close friends
co-worker is dating mark oh do ya in
this post I'm in the post a Reddit user
a chair to picture what appear to be
mark on a date with another woman
she wrote sorry this is awkward because
I live in Atlanta and I've been dating
mark since the beginning of May Elsie
rope oh and by the way this is Elsie
from Love is buying feel free to DM me
on Instagram if you would like more
information why is she like hanging out
on reddit I don't know but like I guess
the story here is that one love it like
after love is fine erred mark started
dating Elsie Elsie and then according to
other reddit users he was dating like
other there was well - and then I guess
Jessica wait into about and she said um
[ __ ] what did she say oh she said wow
this is news to me I only knew about one
so I guess he was cheating like he was
sleeping with multiple women Jessica
knew he was sleeping with one person and
apparently there's like a whole roster
I like really missed the time in my life
where like the biggest news story was
Jessica being 34 and Mark being 24 yeah
I know I miss when that was like how are
we gonna reconcile this yeah and like I
literally miss like logging on to my
phone and just like looking at memes
about love is blind and like literally
like belly laughing so hard that was
such a good happy time in my life yeah
it was like right before warranty in the
beginning of the end
yeah those were good times and good
damn those were good times well I mean I
mean there's something shocking there
other than the fact that he's dating a
cast mate and you know what else is
shocking like Marc really got such this
edit of like poor him like job just did
a number on him and it's like I think
that there was definitely I think if I
were Jessica like I will have like I've
been pissed up until this point yeah
because she was doing that is raw deal
and he's not like just like the sweet
loving guy who was just there waiting
for her at every turn
no but those scenes were like he was
being the loving guy waiting for her at
every turn and she was like being like
the villain like those were some of the
most difficult things I've ever had to
watch like that scene when they when
they make it to the hotel in Mexico and
then they like are in the bed and it's
just like it's awful yeah awful I miss
that show I can't wait for second season
even though it's gonna be ruined by like
thirst monsters now I'm still really
excited for another season yeah I think
I think that they can figure it out I
feel like you could also weed out thirst
monsters easily by just like looking at
people's instagrams what show did you
like better love is blind or too hot to
handle I think love is blind because it
opened up like even though it was like a
silly reality show you really have like
meaningful conversations from it and
like is love blind I don't know to have
to handle was like the opposite of that
it was just like shallow shallow shallow
yeah I agree I loved love is when like I
got so immediately emotionally invested
in the whole thing like when we were on
our way to LA and like the finale came
out like we both downloaded it yeah I've
had like I was really invested because
it was this like elevated meaningful
like bachelor yeah and like people were
having like like people on the show
we're having serious conversations about
a lot of different things and then
afterwards like it just spawned really a
dialogue where it's too hot to handle
it's just like sex like oh yeah it was
honestly borderline porn sometimes but
there was no sex even that's true yeah
so I see like whenever we got to season
two it's gonna mean a long time like I'd
look forward yeah it's gonna be in a
while I look forward to knowing her okay
fifth and final story a little happy
couple news because Raven Symone says
her wedding to Miranda her man Maddie
was a true reflection of their love oh
my god I didn't even know she was
married
Raven Symone got married on June 16th in
an intimate ceremony
this in this week's issue of people the
former Cosby Show actress and her new
wife excuse me
the former Cosby Show actually down the
former That's So Raven star but as like
as we realized in yesterday's episode
like in articles like this they
constantly are like the former like the
toast singer that they just use all
these descriptive ways I mean if anybody
ever really tries the toast singer like
I would die be so excited like so here
like we're about to get to like the
Cheetah Girls right our you know right
um but she exclusively opened up about
their secret wedding which only had six
guests the intimate details and how it
was a reflection of their future
together
she said despite being someone who has
kept my personal life private I decided
to share this moment because it's one of
the biggest and happiest of my life
Miranda makes me feel confident and
empower in an entirely new way we
planned our ceremony together and it was
a true reflection of our love and
partnership that is so cute like I
didn't even know that she got married
anyone else she was dating anyone I just
that's the way to do it you know it's
our people exclusive with the good news
a little good news this is so much good
news so much good news there's like a
really special cockle of my heart for
like just carved out directly for Raven
Symone like I feel like she had such a
big impact on me as a kid like that so
Raven was my favorite [ __ ] show and I
watched it like every day and I used to
laugh so hard it was like my first kind
of experience with comedy like it was so
funny I remember like belly laughing
like silent laughing for like the first
time in my life to an episode where her
hands she eats like mushrooms and she's
allergic to her hands get so big and
she's like doing that cooking show thing
I just there's a special place in my
heart for and I really only want like
good positive happy special things for
her
I completely agree and this seems to be
one of those things so I can't so
excited mom say Mazel Tov so those are
the fastest words and I feel as though
honestly even being honest you needed to
know them bein honest yeah no I
definitely needed to know that to know
them and surprisingly
maybe it's cuz actually like a month ago
I deleted the Twitter app off my phone
it was just like so [ __ ] negative
like and I felt so much better but I
really feel like I know less like I find
myself being shocked when you say
something oh
that's cool yeah that's like what the
show is meant for you know let me just
get like like we got your commentary you
know you know and it's it's so organic
i'msorry gana you're so organic so much
right you don't need to eat organic
because you are or people need to eat me
I can't I feel like people who are so
fake like they're the ones who are
eating organics to try and counteract
them they're the ones that like it's
just so artificial like it's just ironic
you know what I'm saying
it's all about it's all about outs and
I'm the most organic that you've ever
met in your life
and speaking of well not really next up
is our dear toaster segment which is our
advice segment you can always write into
it to your toasters at gmail.com we
always keep it anonymous you can write
in about anything from quarantine
troubles to boyfriend troubles work
stuff anything we'll always keep it
anonymous so let's dive right in
again that's dear toasters at gmail.com
we're running low please write us please
dear my favorite people and my adoptive
and statuses I've gotten literally
everyone I know to listen to the toast
and we're also excited about the comedy
special we are so proud of you both
thank you so much you could pre-order my
comedy special disgraced weena comes out
in six days on iTunes you could search
disgraced screen into iTunes or you just
tap the link in my bio on girl with no
job thank you to whoever wrote this in
for providing my special okay I'm going
into my second year of college and I'd
been dating this guy for two years I
love him and he is my best friend but I
feel guilty for not letting him have the
full college experience and also I want
that I want the time to be alone with
myself and my friends and I'm scared
that if we stay together I'll start to
resent him for that later how do I go
about taking the break what's the time
limit for when we need to revisit do we
just let it happen it's gonna break my
heart but I know it's best for me
sincerely an underage toaster who's
trying to bring my fake ID into camp
toast now I have something just came to
mind for me about this whole scenario
and it was the honestly Oscar snubbed
film how to be single featuring Dakota
Johnson rebel Wilson that movie was a
Razzie snubbed oh my god are you kidding
me I thought that was like the most
amazing movie it's a horrible oh my god
I totally disagree I think it's
literally like the old like spoiler
alert she zips her own dress like I can
oh the zipping of the dress thing I
agree was like a really lame cliche but
she's met this guy in college they spent
all of college together and then at the
end of college he's like so heartbroken
because she's like we're gonna get back
together but I just want to take a break
I just
want to find myself I've never been on
my own la-da-da and then obviously like
she goes to get back together with him
and he like found someone else and he
was like so happy yeah honestly
unpopular opinion she should have stayed
with him of course he was such a great
guy I start from the fact that like he
ended up meeting someone else and like
getting engaged and like still kissed to
coach Johnson at a party but like he was
in love with her and I don't fault him
for that but like I sang his best he's
trying to stuff I I don't love this idea
I'm not gonna lie like this is reminds
me again of the wonderful song grow as
we go by then Platt who said that in
order to grow you need to be apart like
you can grow with someone and grow as we
go grow as we who who said that the
growing only happens on your own why do
you have to grow by yourself
yeah sorry I got like into the song um
my advice I agree with you I think that
like it like - totally Johnson in the
movie the reason why she shouldn't have
broken up with him is because the only
reason she was breaking up with him is
because she felt like she needed that
she's supposed to be single that she's
supposed to see what's out there
I don't think that that should be a
reason why you break up with someone
because you feel like you're supposed to
do something but if there are issues in
the relationship and you want to see
what else is out there because you're
not happy with what you have take a
break and I'm so like she said she said
like I'm gonna be heartbroken
like you don't have the itch to be
single when you're like happy in your
relationship and yeah breakups are sad
but sometimes they're meant like they're
necessary it's necessary pain you need
to grow from it and you take something
into the next relationship so I think if
you're writing into a show like asking
if you should break up with your
boyfriend you should break up with your
boyfriend
well more you should reflect on why you
want to break up do you actually just
want to be single or is there more to it
you know yeah or at least take a break
see where it goes but I do think
generally speaking like when you're so
young especially when you're dating
someone from high school like you grow
you could you can grow together but a
lot of people don't so that's true
so don't like I think this is a very
natural progression yeah you know what I
would I endorse this break I would put
your air pods in listen to grow as we go
by Ben Platt and then see how you feel
afterwards I
think it'll actually this did the truth
is in the song okay and you will find
your truth once you listen to the song
next up
dearest Claudia Jackie first of all love
you girls I'm in need of a little advice
and I think your creative minds will
come up with some great ideas I recently
found out I'm pregnant my husband and I
are so excited
the only thing is that we're not far
along in the pregnancy so we aren't
telling people yet we'll be at the beach
with lots of family in the next week and
my family drinks a lot do you've any
suggestions as to how to fake drink so
no one suspects anything when we're on
the beach it'll be easy because I'll use
a solo cup but what about when we're at
the beach house are playing games at
night I normally drink wine and beer
mixed drinks basically I like alcohol in
case that helps I'll probably tell my
sister before then so she and my husband
will not be able to get me quote drinks
as well thanks in advance
xoxo a sober sober tipsy toaster for
nine months oh that's hard yeah I mean
so this is hard I guess you don't want
to tell them because it makes it a big
things like you could say like you're on
antibiotics there's a ton of reasons why
you wouldn't drink you can also say
we're trying yeah that's a big theme in
season four Potomac
yeah drinking and trying yeah there's
definitely creative ways to get out of
it you're totally right antibiotic is a
good one also you could just be not
feeling well you're trying to cut back
you could say like you're doing whole 30
even though like felt like judge you and
whatever and then you'll be like that
girl but as an organic Queen myself I
totally understand but like then you'll
have kept your secret and eventually
you'll be able to untell them at the
time they thought you did a whole 30
yeah I just feel like the more elaborate
you get into a lie like it's just it
never works out like you get you just
build a web and then you like forget
something you said so you just be like a
plain like an antibiotics like something
that's simple not too complicated
that'll just throw everyone off your
scent yeah or just you could say like
I've been drinking so much you're in
quarantine like I I promised myself I
would do a cleanse like I have I'm
sticking to it
yeah doing like a dry weekend yeah and
you know what like hopefully your family
and friends like aren't so annoying and
they'll just leave you alone let you
live your life yeah but like look I get
that she doesn't want to like raise any
eyebrows like I'm a really big drinker
and like we went away for the weekend
and I didn't drink what would you think
um I was just like if you had a decent
enough reasoning you were like saying
you weren't drinking because you've been
drinking so much and you
don't like the way you've been feeling
like I would totally accept that yeah
okay I think it's also know your
audience like that's an excuse it I
would accept because I've been there
yeah like if you said to me on my Nana
biotics I'd be like what well yeah yeah
there would be follow-up questions yeah
but I know you too well to know that
you're not on antibiotics but so there's
no your audience tailor the excuse to
something that would strike a chord
within them right or that they couldn't
further just prove like not an
antibiotic so I just saw you you know at
the doctor you know so that wasn't
really helpful but just figure it out
and you know what at the end of the day
honesty is the best policy
yeah and if they don't accept and they
might be like you're Bergman I just I
just be like you know maybe just don't
go to the beach yeah obviously like the
more we talk about it like it the less
we can help you so maybe just stay home
yeah yeah my favorite piece of advice to
give people during cures all right
finally hi Jackie
and Claudia and crunchy Theodora crunchy
angel Dora precious chanting Dora la vie
boy Dora one-and-only Dora favorite
nephew Dora beautiful chair and Dora
precious path' Dora
delicious lips Dora loving man Dora
crunchy anal Dora
beautiful perfect Dora I guess we're
still going Dora never stopping Dora my
son my angel Dora I love him Dora so do
i Dora Dora I think we should stop now
next up hi Claudia Jackie and okay I
need your help
my best friend wants to be an influencer
and it's driving me insane she's
talented creative and beautiful but her
feet is so full of [ __ ] captions
she's monologuing on her instace Tory's
having deep conversations in her teams
and trying to grow her brand in ways
that don't add up to who she is in real
life the problem is I know her too well
I know that most of what she's saying is
totally untrue and that she does not
have her [ __ ] together in real life she
centers a lot of
content around giving advice which is
concern I know that being online means
that you can be that you can bend the
truth but I know too much I can't take
her seriously I want her to be
successful but I cannot handle this
[ __ ] how can I be a supportive
friend while I can't stand her online
persona mute her talk to her suck it up
help things to note she doesn't make any
money from her Instagram she doesn't
have that many followers less than
10,000 and she has no clue that I feel
this way Thank You a toaster who was
probably a horrible friend
that's so infuriating like it's
infuriating I've seen I see both sides
like I totally like know people like
this who's like instagrams like makes me
want to die and it's like I know you
like you're evil like your Instagram is
just not reflective of who you are but
at the same time it said this is your
friend like this is her what she wants
for her life like let her live yeah I
agree but I mean how close can you guys
be it's like this is really if this is
like what she's getting into you know
like they really bothers you can also I
want to say her friend like definitely
need her don't look at it if you don't
see it it won't bother you and then when
she like asks you about stuff you like
oh I haven't seen that yet and go and
look at it but just try not to read
everything otherwise you like you will
inevitably just like make fun of her
behind her back constantly and like
that's not friendship
yeah and at the same time like what the
key you know at people ask me all the
time the key to being a successful
influencer is being organic which I'm so
organic right and it's also like being
authentic so if she's really putting out
this like totally fake persona like and
her whole brand is like a mask she'll
really never be successful which it
seems like you don't want her to be so
maybe she'll just give it up soon right
she won't be successful doing it this
way so she will give up if she needs to
like make a living right um I'm curious
about this girl's finances like how does
she pay around to she have another job
and like the influencing is a side
project is she working on her passion
project full-time maybe she's a student
maybe yeah yeah so I don't know I think
everything will work itself out yeah
while it's bothering you just try not to
look at it yeah like if you're still
bothered by it just like keep your nose
out of other people's business but like
it's she's not putting her nose in the
business like she follows her friend and
the captions come up and she's like far
as far as far he would just scroll
scroll down scrolling
keep on scrolling those were our dear
toasters clearly we are desperate for
entries so please write in too dear
toasters at gmail.com we found
everyone's problems
maybe maybe our advice is too good
people don't want to face their like
no vices so good we solve people's lives
and then like they don't need to write
in and then don't come back but the
email is dear toasters achieve a calm
feel free to write in anything we always
keep it anonymous and we promise we
won't make kind of a oh my comedy
special is out in six days but just like
such a big deal I cannot even stress it
enough so if you haven't pre-ordered it
yet I can't stress enough like how
important it is that you do pre-order it
so you could tap the link in my bio on
girls in a job or you could just type in
disgraced Queen into iTunes and it'll
pop right up for pre-order it's like I
said six days away and it's just it's
just beautiful yeah beautiful stunning
and smart it's just beautiful Claudia
that is beautiful thank you anything you
want to promote not much but head over
to patreon if you're looking for some
extra content yes we filmed a fabulous
patreon podcast episode two days ago and
it's one of my favorites so if you sign
up today you pay $1 a month and you get
five extra episodes for $7.99 you get
for $7.99 you get five extra episodes a
month from Jackie and I whether that's
video or podcast episodes and if you
sign up now you get access to all the
old episodes since we started like over
two years ago so that's like 200
episodes so there's really no reason for
you not to be a pH remember at this
point sorry sweetie
well I think that's all she wrote I'm
looking at her she moved to the new
studio with us and she's just she's been
in the corner like for the last hour
sprite she's like a what's it called I'm
a court reporter yeah thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning toast
the millenium morning show or we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching us
on YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we are
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so it's about if I
iTunes stitcher public radio I already
can spot so the places where ever you
listen to podcast find us we're in
testing faster via but a beautiful
stunning and smart we are love you guys
so much we hope you have a great day bye